this is the brand-new version of
MacLaren's most accessible car it was
made as a more usable daily driving
friendly version of the f1 developed
machines that McLaren lovers my thigh
on our outing we drove this car with
winter tires on its 19 inch alloy rims
now those type of tires definitely
affect how supercars handle through
their multiple drive modes but they
proved perfect on this drive because we
shot this video through a thunderstorm
in the Swiss countryside it was the
perfect scenario to really test just how
well this white lightning machine would
do as a daily driver the 570s has a 3.8
liter twin-turbo v8 engine that gets 570
horsepower on a 7-speed automatic
transmission 0 to 60 miles per hour is
3.1 seconds the handling in the 570s is
fantastic it's exactly what you'd expect
from McLaren the brakes are so sensitive
it's actually very easy to drive and for
a car of this caliber that's really
saying something it has way more
visibility than most Lamborghinis that
you drive so it's much easier and more
practical if you can use that work to
drive even though it is a really
high-end car even more surprising is the
fact that the 570s gets 38 miles per
gallon on the highway you could say the
570s
passed our rainy day driving test with
flying colors and it looked good the
entire time the 570s has new front and
rear lamps plus special arrow blades
side skirts and a rear air diffuser that
all make it totally unique and
distinctive the doors open high which
means you can park this car in tight
spaces and though the trunk is small it
looks bigger than the trunk you would
find in any Lamborghini or Bugatti at
180 for $900 the 570s costs 80 grand
less in the McLaren 650s equal to about
what you'd spend on a Porsche 911 Turbo
S and just about 10 grand less than what
you'd spend on a Ferrari California the
mclaren 570s is a very fun car to drive
in that unquantifiable way that only the
best cars are